here's Peter Ducey asking Biden about
all of this and he's referencing what
you talked about Josh there's a Corvette
there so everything's got to be secure
classified material next to your
Corvette what were you thinking
let me uh we're going to get a chance to
speak on all this God willing soon but
as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvette's in
the lock garage okay so it's not like
you're sitting on the streets but
anyways
yes as well as my Corvette
um but as I said earlier this week
people know I take classified documents
or classified materials seriously
it's just so stupid like he's so muddled
and he reads very poorly the statement
right after that but like the garage
saying the garage is locked everyone
keeps their crap in the garage that's
what you keep in the garage if someone
was going to break into my house and
they would ask me before and hey which
room would you prefer you break into I
would say the garage that's all the crap
I have all the plastic cups in there and
the the seasonal
compare the garage to where Trump was
allegedly storing these documents in
Mar-A-Lago which was in a skiff and you
know this difference between an
ex-president and an ex-vice president
which you hinted at earlier Dave this
makes all the difference in the world so
you know I'm a lawyer by background I'll
do the whole constitutional law thing
just for a second here so article two of
US Constitution invests the executive
power in one person in the president of
the United States and the president of
the United States alone what that means
is I said in my column this morning is
that the vice president has no more
executive power properly construed than
any other cabinet official or frankly
than a White House janitor so the vice
president is completely is completely
incapable of making any kind of spot
declassification classification
decisions Barack Obama when he was
president he could have made those
decisions Joe Biden now that he's
president can make those decisions but
when Joe Biden was vice president he had
no power whatsoever and another thing
that every Office of the ex-president
and has you know being a former
president of the United States is a
pretty big deal you get kind of lifelong
Secret Service protection and you get
this skiff to host personal copies of
your records from your time at the White
House vice presidents again do not get
that so this distinction is a big big
big difference there and you know
frankly after kind of the first
revelation of the bed at the Penn Biden
Center earlier this week and my reaction
was like a little muddled I was like
okay this is like really really bad but
you know I'm told by the mainstream
media that it's not the ton of that it's
not a ton of documents now after
yesterday's news with these two tranches
of documents that there were a bunch in
the garage and apparently there was one
other document they found elsewhere in
the house I I really do think this is
considerably worse considerably worse
than what happened to president Trump
given all that we just said there and
obviously yes the world saw you know
Mar-A-Lago got this unprecedented FBI
pre-dawn raid Joe Biden's Corvette
Garage in Wilmington Delaware has
received no such treatment at all
if you'd like more sane takes on our
insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell